hey Jeremy Gibson from verdun Illinois
had to write out a script so that I
could actually get the question right um
what if the Big Bang is nothing more
than the eventual explosion of a black
hole when its energy is not enough to
keep everything it has pulled in inside
in theory it is an exceptionally dense
rotating ball of matter right so Jeremy
it's a great question first let me point
out that nobody knows but secondly the
people that work very hard on
understanding the beginning of
everything the Big Bang they have not
come up with the idea that it was a
single black hole just this week people
discovered the star they're calling
nasty which created a disk a thousand
times the diameter of the solar system
the scale of the thing is really hard to
get the reason I think that your idea
about being a single black hole is
probably not right as the scale of it
there are at least 10 to the 85th atoms
in the observable universe any black
hole or started we've come a lot come
across just just not not that big if I'm
not in close to that big when you start
talking about dozens of orders of
magnitude
dozens of factors of 10 it's it's just
the Big Bang was a big deal I mean you
and I and everything that we can observe
came from it as far as we can tell so
you may be right and maybe this star
nasty will lead to a discovery that will
inform your question but right now I
think you're just you're not
appreciating how big everything is or
how big everything must have been and
then there's this question jeremy of the
unknowable time there's a time according
to sort of first cut relativity there's
a time we can't know because of the
quantum because there's the energies
either here or it's not there and so
people just love to speculate about what
happened in that moment and maybe you
will be that a guy the guy who discovers
it maybe your question will give an
astrophysicists an idea and he or she
will go wow I got it and we will all
stay tuned
- cool question Jeremy